I just brought this over in second
example hi Bubba
oh no no you would you relax I brought
them to you you want your little baby
with your baby or do you go pop oh hey
how's it going no you sleep you snores
away you sleepy I'll sleep with you ah
is that good I haven't done a good old
floor vlog in a while
hey pay me like one of your friends
youtubers excuse me I know the fans love
you more but this is not necessary
hey guys uh how's it going bet you
wonder where I've been so this past week
I have been absent it hasn't it's been a
while since I've missed one day let
alone a whole week mysteriously and I
explained it in a vlog while I was over
at the location where we were filming at
but there was no internet there and and
that's not lie like later today I'm
going to upload like five videos because
I recorded them ahead of time and I
meant to upload them but when we were
there I was like for some reason I
didn't just upload them here I was like
oh upload there I don't care if it takes
overnight even that video that I showed
you like I uploaded that from my phone
because I was standing on that balcony
and just holding my phone out over the
edge of a fee abyss I'm sorry puppy this
is her baby because it still has its
face chica is a vicious beast that tears
the face off of every I thought this
adorable puppy would be on slope oh no
I'm just a little bit decapitated so
this past week I've been filming with a
bunch of my friends out in the boonies
as I call them but we were filming at
this castle for this multi-part video
that we're gonna release soon and I
would love to tell you all about it I
really would the rest of the team would
kill me if I did but I would want to
tell you about it and that's not just me
reverse psychology getting you to like
be hyped about it like I really want to
tell you oh well but trust me when I say
it's one of those things that the less
you know about it now the better it will
be for you when you actually see it's a
huge project we've never done anything
this big or
ambitious it's not a YouTube red series
it's not a movie it's just a project
that we were very passionate about and
we wanted to do the best we could at and
we did like this past week has been
amazing and admittedly this past week
has been not good for videos on this
channel I know I broke some bronzers
there hand
I mean what can I do what can you do
about that and now that I was dismissing
the the aspect of promises or keeping
promises but this past week has been
like fulfilling for me and in a way that
I haven't seen like like me filming a
project be fulfilling in a while
number one because it was something that
we all were very very passionate about
it's something that we all like really
really loved what you looking for book
it was something that we were all
supremely passionate about and it was
something that really really something
that really really gave me more insight
on myself and that's what weird thing to
say especially considering I'm 28 years
old now like I'm a full-fledged adult
I've been paying taxes for years now I
have an accountant like I am an adult
I'm about as adult as it comes and I
know you guys are currently typing up
your examples of how I'm not an adult
I'm a meme chugging idiot but that's
besides the point the point of the
matter is I learned more about myself
even though I've been in this body for I
didn't make any sense but then again
nothing I say does but it's funny
because everything I do is a reflection
of Who I am right
like these videos that I make they're a
reflection of who I am
because I'm honest and even though that
honesty is never a lie that doesn't mean
that I can't change over time I used to
be caught up in this vicious cycle of oh
man I could have been so good at this if
I had started then or if I if I'd have
been doing this instead of that and and
and that's why I make like such sweeping
statements like promises like I'll never
miss an upload date and and admittedly
the day after I posted that video I was
like oh I judge myself a hole now how am
I
to get out of this one more hell you
can't you're just an idiot you gotta
live with it but what but the reason I
said that is because I was mad at myself
and the reason I was mad at myself was
because I was getting lazy like it
really was and that's what caught me
that's what made me go like oh what are
you doing no and then like as like
penance for myself I created this
schedule that I never wanted to break
and admittedly I wasn't gonna break it
if the internet wasn't there today I am
gonna upload just a whole bunch of
videos you guys are gonna see him today
I've got a ton of Wes to Loathing in the
in the pocket that I'll be spreading out
throughout the day it's like it was a
kick in the ass and sometimes you just
need a kick in the ass even if you're
kicking your own ass sometimes
you just need to be kicked in the ass
and that's where that's where I can come
across as an sometimes
like I care a lot about what we do here
and I care a lot about this community
that we've built so while at the same
time I like to kick in the ass for what
it did for me work ethic wide I didn't
like the kick in the ass because it
caused me to post videos at any cost you
know what I mean
and that means that I'll post a video
that I'm not too happy with and that's
like my number one I don't want to make
videos that I'm not happy with because
everything I do I pour my heart and soul
into and I want that to be shown like
the honesty of who I am is apparent to
everybody that watches this because I am
just me and I'll only ever be me and so
the only way that I can ever be better
is by being true to myself and yes I
will change but in the long run that
change will hopefully be for the better
because you guys are there to correct
with me punk that's endeavour like does
that make any sense I know that's a lot
of words and whatnot but it's
what I was realizing this weekend like I
love making videos I love these big
projects I love pushing myself to do
great things while at the same time
trying to keep up this rigorous schedule
it's a challenge and it's a balance and
it's something that's really fun because
while at the same time I love doing
these videos I also
love doing on other projects like I've
been falling in love with music lately
like I've been listening to so much ed
Sheeran a little bit of James Arthur
like Harry Styles I love his new song
sign of the times
like I've found myself falling into
music and it's something that I want to
I want to dedicate my time to but then
again there's just not enough time today
to do everything so I just find myself
having to hmm spread myself pretty thin
that's it that like that's it that's the
longer the short of it there is no end
goal here there is no business I'm
building there's no nothing else there's
no long-term plan because the video the
videos that I make in this channel is
the most accurate reflection of my life
I could possibly make and the fact that
you guys are along for the journey is
just the biggest honor I could ever hope
for and this community that we've built
and the causes that we rally for are
just like it's just the most delightful
thing that I could ever hope for
and I know delightful's not the word to
use for that but I don't care like
that's a description that I can make for
it whenever I see the fact that we rally
around these things and you guys are
there for me for these videos and not to
kiss your ass about it but I like listen
I really do I really do love you guys
I do and I know it's such a mean to say
that about your fanbase and I know
everyone's like oh no I love my fans I
love my fans I would do anything for my
fans and I know it's such a joke to say
that at this point but God just thank
you like honestly thank you like thank
you a million times the fact that I'm
able to do this and projects like this
you know they're like they in there
there's so time it's intensive and they
take so many resources and it costs a
lot of money and I don't care like I
don't care like I don't care about any
of that like I just care about making
the best things that I can make because
I owe it to you you know
I owe it to you guys to push myself and
not that I'm ever gonna hurt myself for
your benefit like if they called me on
my I'd like to think that the
thing you guys stick around for is the
fact that I'm but I have no idea what
I'm doing and that means that I can do
anything at any moment and I think
that's cool but change is good sometimes
sometimes is but sometimes it's
good you know it's worth the risk
you can't stay stagnant forever if
things stay the same forever we'd never
go anywhere right so for the good of the
bad I will keep changing and I'll keep
thanking you guys so also we're doing a
charity campaign this uh
this week this month is for the joyful
Heart Foundation and for this particular
charity I am not going to be doing a
charity livestream and that's not out of
laziness I do have time I could do one
tomorrow I could have done one last
weekend and I had really thought about
it but the reason why I can't do a
charity livestream for this cause is not
because I don't want to support it as
much as anything else I've ever done
it's because the joyful Heart Foundation
is for victims of sexual assault I am
not the right person to be a champion
for that cause I have never experienced
sexual assault and in a livestream
setting where usually I talk about you
know stories about I talk about I talk
to people to share their stories about
it and the fact of the matter is there
are people that are currently going
through the healing process of dealing
with these sexual assaults and it would
almost be detrimental to certain
people's healing process to bring that
up and make people relive it so for this
one I will only say there is merch down
in the description there is at Ulta
five-page for donations for the joyful
Heart Foundation the merge proceeds go
to the charity I don't make any money
off of it the donations go directly to
the charity I don't take any of it I'm
gonna donate myself and please just help
out this great cause and in addition to
that currently there's flooding in
Houston
Texas from hurricane Henry like I'll
also put a link in the description for
like various foundations that will help
out in the aid and relief efforts for
helping the victims of the flooding and
helping like search parties to do that
so please if you can donate to either
those causes take your pick
they're both great efforts and you know
just my heart goes out to everybody
that's been affected by it and like we
did a show in Houston like we were there
like we were just there I've only ever
seen it once and it was during that show
and like I just can't imagine that just
to all of that just being flooded away
it's it's heartbreaking and again I'm
like I'm not the right spokesperson to
say about it because I didn't live in
Houston so all I can do is ask you guys
to help out and help out wherever you
can even if you're nearby maybe even a
volunteer effort would be good so yeah I
think that's about the long this short
of all I wanted to talk about today so
thank you everybody so much for watching
there will be a ton of videos coming up
this week and I'm going to pax at the
end of this week so if you're going
there I'll see you there and it should
be a fun time
like there's exciting videos coming and
there's not exciting videos coming and
then there's really mediocre videos
coming and then there's gonna be highs
and lows to everything but thanks for
staying with me it means the world and
it means you will do BP right butch are
you thanks again and as always I will
see you in the next video buh-bye